I'm gonna tell you story I'm gonna tell
you a story about how the deadliest
consumer product imaginable came to be
it's the cigarette the cigarette is the
only consumer product that when used as
intended will kill half of all long-term
users prematurely later in life but this
is also a story about the work that
we're doing at the Food and Drug
Administration and specifically the work
that we're doing to create the cigarette
of the future that is no longer capable
of creating or sustaining addiction a
lot of people think that the tobacco
problem or the smoking problem has been
solved in the United States because of
the great progress that's been made over
the last 40 50 years when it comes to
both consumption and prevalence and it's
true smoking rates are at historic lows
it's true for both adults and for kids
and it's true that those who continue to
smoke are smoking far fewer cigarettes
per day than at any time in history
but what if I told you that tobacco use
primarily because of firsthand and
secondhand exposure to the smoke in
cigarettes remains the leading cause of
completely preventable disease and death
in this country well that's true and
what if I told you that it's actually
killing more people than we thought to
be the case ever before that's true too
smoking kills more people each year than
alcohol aids car accidents illegal drugs
murders and suicides combined year in
and year out in 2014 dr. Adams
predecessor released the fiftieth
anniversary surgeon general's report on
smoking and health and that report upped
the annual death toll from smoking
because the list the smoking related
illnesses
got bigger
and so it is now conservatively
estimated that smoking kills four
hundred and eighty thousand Americans
every year these are completely
preventable deaths how do we wrap our
heads around a statistic like this so
much of what we've heard at this
conference is about individual
experiences and personal experiences how
do we deal with this at a population
level when there are four hundred and
eighty thousand moms dads sisters
brothers aunts and uncles dying
unnecessary deaths every year from
tobacco and then what happens when you
think about this trajectory for the
future and just do the simple math from
the time of the 50th anniversary surgeon
general's report five years ago when
this horrible statistic was raised just
through mid-century that's more than 17
million avoidable deaths in the United
States from tobacco use primarily
because of cigarettes the Surgeon
General concluded that 5.6 million
children alive in the United States in
2014 will die prematurely later in life
because of cigarettes 5.6 million
children so this is an enormous public
health problem for all of us but
especially for us as regulators at the
Food and Drug Administration in the
Center for tobacco products what can we
do about it what can we do to reverse
this trajectory of disease and death
well we have an interesting guide to
help unravel issues like how did the
cigarette as we know it come to be what
is the true nature of the tobacco and
cigarette business how did the industry
behave in the historically unregulated
marketplace and our guide is previously
secret internal documents from the
tobacco industry come with me in a
tobacco industry document time machine
1963 was 25 years before the Surgeon
General was finally able to conclude
that the nicotine and cigarettes was
addictive that did not happen until the
Surgeon General's report in 1998 1963
was one year before the first-ever
Surgeon General's report in 1964
I remember 1964 I don't remember the
Surgeon General's report but I remember
1964 I was a kid growing up in Brooklyn
New York this was at a time when almost
1 in 2 adults in the United States
smoked both of my parents were heavy
smokers at the time tobacco use was so
incredibly normalized that and this
wasn't North Carolina Virginia or
Kentucky this was Brooklyn
we made ashtrays for our parents and
arts and crafts class the ashtrays I
made were pretty awful but they were
ashtrays so normalized that I remember
seeing a bowl of loose cigarettes in the
foyer of our house and other houses as a
welcoming gesture when friends came over
for a visit okay we're back in 1963 the
top lawyer for Brown & Williamson which
was then the third largest cigarette
company in the United States wrote the
following nicotine is addictive we are
then in the business of selling nicotine
an addictive drug
it's a remarkable statement as much for
what it doesn't say is for what it does
say he didn't say they were in the
cigarette business he didn't say they
were in the tobacco business he said
they were in the business of selling
nicotine Philip Morris in 1972 the
cigarette isn't a product it's a package
the product is nicotine the pack is a
storage container for a day's supply of
nicotine the cigarette a dispenser for a
dose unit of nicotine we'll come back to
this dose unit notion later and r.j.
Reynolds in 1972 in a sense the tobacco
industry may be thought of as being a
specialized high
ritualize and style.i segment of the
pharmaceutical industry tobacco products
uniquely contain and deliver nicotine a
potent drug with variety of
physiological effects at the time and
for many decades publicly the industry
completely denied addiction and
completely denied causality but they
knew the true nature of their business
and from time to time there have been
health scares made public about
cigarettes going back many decades how
did the industry respond and how did
they respond in this historically
unregulated marketplace going back to
the 1930s it was with advertising that
heavily featured imagery of doctors and
other health care professionals sending
messages of reassurance this is an ad
for Lucky Strikes the popular cigarette
of the time in the 30s
twenty thousand six hundred and seventy
nine physicians say Lucky's are less
irritating your throat protection
against irritation against coffee we
laugh but this was the kind of
advertising that was there to send a
health message of reassurance fast
forward to the 1950s 60s and 70s and
here again in the absence of regulation
what we're going to see is modifications
to the product and product design to
respond to the health concerns of the
day this is the Kent Micra night filter
and here the innovation if you will was
the filtered cigarette full smoking
pleasure plus proof of the greatest
health protection ever what the smoker
of this product didn't know what their
doctor didn't know what the government
didn't know is that this was the filter
that was lined with asbestos so that
when smokers were smoking this filtered
cigarette and still inhaling the
chemicals in smoke that we know are
associated with cancer and lung disease
and heart disease
they were also sucking down asbestos
fibers in the 1960s in the 1970s the
so-called innovation was the light
cigarette this is a
typical brand of the day called truth
and this is after the Surgeon General's
reports have started coming out and you
see the the look of concern on her face
considering all I'd heard I decided to
either quit or smoke true I smoked true
the low-tar low-nicotine cigarette and
then it says think about it and then
even below that in the small print art
are numbers and nicotine numbers what
was a light cigarette how did it work
this is an illustration of the product
modification known as filter ventilation
that's not a real filter blown up that's
just a picture so that you could see the
rows of laser perforated ventilation
holes that were put on the filter when
you look at a real cigarette it's harder
to see every patent for this product
shows that the ventilation holes should
be 12 millimeters from the lip end of
the filter how did it work the cigarette
got stuck into a machine the Machine
started puffing away on the cigarette
and recording tar nicotine levels as the
machine smoked outside air came through
those ventilation holes and diluted the
amount of smoke that was coming through
the cigarette so as the machine smoked
there really was less tar and nicotine
being delivered compared to a regular
cigarette what the tobacco industry knew
was that human beings don't smoke like
machines how do human beings smoke this
where did the fingers go where did the
lips go I told you that the patent said
that the holes are 12 millimeters from
the lip end the smoker didn't even know
they were there but between fingers and
lips the holes get blocked and when the
holes get blocked it's no longer a light
cigarette turns out that there's
actually basically as much nicotine
inside a light cigarette as a regular
cigarette the difference was what's on
the outside but once you block what's on
the outside it's a regular cigarette
Congress put FDA in the business of
regulating tobacco products ten years
ago this Jim
so you heard the statistics at the
beginning about the extraordinary
contribution to disease and death that
cigarettes make we've also been taking
paying a lot of attention to how the
cigarette works as a drug delivery
device and the remarkable efficiency
with which it delivers nicotine so let's
take a look when the smoker puffs on the
cigarette the nicotine from that puff
gets up into the brain in less than 10
seconds less than 10 seconds up in the
brain there are these things called
nicotinic receptors they're there
waiting they're waiting for in the words
of that Philip Morris document the next
dose unit of nicotine the smoker that
you see outside huddled with other
smokers in the cold and the wind in the
rain is experiencing craving and maybe
experiencing the symptoms of withdrawal
those symptoms of withdrawal are a
chemical message that these receptors
are sending to the body saying feed me
and a product that can deliver the drug
in less than 10 seconds turns out to be
an incredibly efficient and incredibly
addictive product we've spoken to so
many addiction treatment experts over
the years and the story I hear is the
same over and over again long after I
was able to get somebody off of heroin
or cocaine or crack cocaine I can't get
them to quit cigarettes a large part of
the explanation is the ten second thing
FDA has it within its regulatory reach
to use the tools of product regulation
to render cigarettes as we know them
minimally or non addictive we're working
on this and this could have a profound
impact at a population level from this
one policy we did dynamic population
level modeling a year ago and we
published the results in the New England
Journal and because of the generational
effect of this policy which I'll explain
in the
here's what we project out through the
end of the century more than 33 million
people who would otherwise have gone on
to become regular smokers won't because
the cigarette that they'll be
experimenting with can't create or
sustain addiction this would drive the
adult smoking rate down to less than one
and a half percent and these two things
combined would result in the saving of
more than 8 million cigarette related
deaths that would otherwise have
occurred from the generational impact of
this now why do i why am i saying
generational it's about kids
90% of adult smokers started smoking
when they were kids
half of them became regular smokers
before they were legally old enough to
buy a pack of cigarettes
half of them became regular smokers
before they were 18 years old
experimentation regular smoking
addiction decades of smoking and then
the illness and that's why we're talking
about a product that will kill half of
all long-term users prematurely later in
life the generational impact of this
nicotine reduction policy is profound
those old industry documents had a word
for young people they were described as
the replacement smokers the replacement
smokers for addicted adult smokers who
died or quit future generations of kids
especially teens are going to engage in
risky behavior we can't stop that but
what if the only cigarette that they
could get their hands on could no longer
create our sustain addiction that's the
public health return on investment at a
population level over time haven't said
anything about e-cigarettes but I have
to say something about e-cigarettes
we are dealing with an epidemic of kids
use of e-cigarettes and and what
troubles us the most in combination with
the rising numbers when it comes to
prevalence is frequency not only are
more kids using e-cigarettes but more
kids are using e-cigarettes 20 or more
days in the past 30 days than at any
time since these cigarettes came onto
the market and at FDA we're doing
everything that we can using program and
policy first to get the word out to kids
that this is not a harmless product and
to make sure the kids aren't initiating
and experimenting on any tobacco product
whether combustion is present or not but
think about e-cigarettes in a properly
regulated marketplace is something that
could be of benefit to addicted adult
cigarette smokers who are trying to
transition away from cigarettes so I'll
leave you with this vision imagine a
world where the only cigarette that
future generations of kids could
experiment with could no longer create
or sustain addiction because of a single
policy imagine a world where health
concern cigarette smokers especially if
a policy goes into effect that takes the
nicotine levels down to minimally or
non-addictive levels could transition to
alternative and less harmful forms of
nicotine delivery starting with FDA
approved nicotine medications like the
gum patch and Lawson and finally imagine
a world in a properly regulated
marketplace whether it's east cigarettes
or whatever the technology of the day
it's not the product developers and the
marketers who decide which products come
to market and what claims get made for
them it's review scientists at FDA who
look at applications and decide using
the standard that Congress has entrusted
us to implement and enforce whether a
particular product should come to market
because the marketing of that product in
the words of our law would be
appropriate for the protection of the
public health these are the kinds of
powerful regulatory tools that are
within our reach to deal with what
remains the leading cause of completely
preventable disease and death in the
country if we get this right that
trajectory those 5.6 million kids
is breakable thank you
[Music]